House of the Dragon definitely didn't
skimp on the targaryen's favorite fire
breathing mounts and every one of them
has a story to tell
the largest of Daenerys targaryen's
Three Dragons drogon hatches in the
Dothraki sea during Fire and Blood the
season one finale of Game of Thrones he
and his brothers rhaegel and viserion
are a Wonder at the time of their birth
dragons have been extinct for nearly 200
years and are little more than Legends
but then Daenerys strides out of her
husband's funeral pyre with baby drogon
on her shoulder Game of Thrones devotes
much time to her experiences as the
era's first Dragon Rider drogon grows
quickly born in 298 AC the black and red
dragon is the size of a horse when
Daenerys takes Marine in season 4 in 301
AC
[Music]
one season later he's large enough for
the mother of dragons to ride after he
rescues her from an attack by the sons
of the harpy by season 7 approximately
304 AC drogon is as big as a Boeing 747.
he's last seen flying East to volantis
with daenerys's body after she's killed
by Jon Snow for most of the series Regal
is overshadowed by his brother drogon
the green dragon gets to shine in season
8 however when he's ridden by Jon Snow
Regal is green and bronze with Brilliant
Orange eyes like viserion rhaegel's
growth is stunted after Daenerys
imprisons him beneath the Great Pyramid
during season 4 along with visery
although smaller than drogon rhaegal is
still absolutely enormous when he
arrives at Dragonstone in season 7.
Regal faces off against his Undead
brother during season Eight's the long
night where he's wounded in battle sadly
Regal's life comes to an unceremonious
end when he shot down by scorpions
known for his cream and gold coloring
viserion is a more Placid Dragon than
his bigger brother drogon this might be
partially due to his being imprisoned in
Marines catacombs alongside rhaegel in
season 5 Daenerys feeds rhaegal and
viserion a few enemies after sir barrist
and selmy is killed by the sons of the
harpy then in season 6 the dragons
proceed to break free from the catacombs
to help Daenerys and drogon put an end
to the slaver's siege by the Time Season
7 rolls around viserion appears to be
roughly the same size as rhaego sadly
his might cannot save him from the night
King who kills reanimates and rides him
the icy fiend uses the undead dragon's
flame to destroy the wall and unleash
his army on Westeros viserion dies again
when Arya Stark kills the night King
whether this will be viserion's fate in
the books remains unknown
the most legendary dragon to Grace
westerosa Skies balerion the black dread
was brought from valyria to Dragonstone
by the fleeing targaryens by the time
aegon the first set out to conquer
Westeros Valerian was so large that his
shadow engulfed entire Villages Valerian
was aegon's most valuable weapon the
black dreads Fierce flame devastated
harrenhal and house [ __ ] King viserys
rode balerion once in 93 AC by then the
dragon was too old to fly properly a
year later the black dread died his
immense skull can be seen in House of
the dragon and Game of Thrones
surrounded by Reverend candles
caraxi's is Damon targaryen's Dragon an
unusual creature he's often referred to
as the blood worm and it's not hard to
see why craxius has an elongated and
sinuous neck Crimson scales and a
thinner build than most of his Brethren
he is especially impressive when
deployed against the crowd feeder and
the triarchy's forces during the war for
the stepstones alongside his Valerian
steel sword Dark sister karaxy's is
Damon targaryen's biggest weapon Damon
and Elena valarian enjoy a honeymoon
tour of the free cities on karaxi's and
vegar after they marry sadly this
harmony ends with Lena's death
House of the Dragon introduces fans to
Cyrax in episode 1 The Heirs of the
Dragon written by rhaenyra Targaryen The
Golden Dragon takes the princess for a
flight above King's Landing nearly 200
years before Daenerys and drogon destroy
it Cyrax continues to play an important
role throughout the series early
episodes she lights the funeral pyre for
Rainier's Mother after the queen dies in
childbirth in episode 2 Rainier takes
Iraq's to Dragonstone where she
confronts Damon and demands he returned
the dragon egg he stole compared to
karaxi's Cyrax is relatively small and
significantly less experienced in battle
but her sleekness and Agility are also
clear assets and her distinctive color
makes her an impressive sight to behold
sea smoke makes his debut in episode 3
of House of the Dragon second of his
name he's ridden into the battle of the
stepstones by Lenor valarian the
Striking gray Dragon small Nimble and
bonds with Lenor soon after hatching sea
smoke retreats to his lair on
Dragonstone and refuses to accept
another rider for nearly 10 years after
lenor's death in the books assuming
House of the Dragon doesn't stray too
far from The Source material in future
Seasons we haven't seen the lust of sea
smoke
the most dominant dragon on House of the
Dragon is without a doubt vegar born 52
years before the fall of valyria vegar
is the only surviving member of aegon
the First's original Trio by the time
the events of the series begin she's
almost as large as Valerian a seasoned
veteran of many battles and famed for
her hot temper young Elena valarian
mentions vegar in episode 2 during her
conversation with viserys this is
fitting as Lena later rides vegar
herself with Valerian died the last
memory of valyria of old
but Vegas lives
originally written by vicenia Targaryen
during aegon's Conquest Veigar is
subsequently claimed by Valen Targaryen
then Lena and after Lena dies aim and
one eye younger brother of aegon II
vegar changes the tide for the greens
the giant dragon ambushes Rainier his
son luceris valarian and his Dragon
Eric's killing them both
melees known as the Red Queen is written
by rhaenys Targaryen throughout the
dance of the dragons with her Vivid
Crimson coloring it's easy to see where
melis gets her nickname from before
rainy's claims her in 87 AC melees is
flown by Alyssa Targaryen daughter of
king jaharis and queen alisan the
impressive Red Queen is said to be
faster than all other dragons easily
outlying karaxi's and vagar in her prime
princess Alyssa takes her son the Future
King viserys flying on melees at just
nine days old after Alyssa's death melis
accepts rhinis as her new Rider she's
every bit as daring as Alyssa in 90 AC
rhaenys arrives to her wedding to
Corliss Valerian on Dragon back by the
time war is declared within House
Targaryen The Red Queen is a lazier
creature but she's still a force to be
reckoned with as she proves during the
Battle Above rook's rest
written by aegon II Sunfire plays a
crucial role in the dance of the Dragons
Sunfire is young but battle-hearted the
dragon turns the tide in a decisive
battle in Fire and Blood this Victory
comes at Great cost however sunfire's
Wing is torn from his body forcing him
to remain after the battle while a
wounded aegon Retreats Fire and Blood
details sunfire's recovery as Kristen
Cole keeps the dragon well fed with
sheep eventually sunfire's Wing heals
enough for him to fly but at an awkward
angle that hinders him in battle
the yet to be seen dream fire is one of
the older dragons featured on House of
the Dragon the blue and silver creature
hatches during aegon The conqueror's
Reign around 32 AC and initially bonds
with Reina aegon's granddaughter who
rides the she Dragon for the first time
at the age of 12. dream fire accompanies
Reina throughout her turbulent life from
King's Landing to casterly rock to Fair
Isle after Reina dream fire is claimed
by Helena targary daughter of viserys
and Allison and sister wife of aegon II
Helena adores her Dragon dream fire is
never used in combat throughout the
dance of the Dragons despite her age and
size but her historical Legacy is
enormous Fire and Blood suggests that
dreamfire may be drogon rhaegal and
viserion's mother Reyna's lover Alyssa
farman absconds with three of
dreamfire's eggs which are strongly
implied to be the ones eventually given
to Daenerys by Magister illyrio mapatis
in the books dreamfire is said to break
her chains in the dragon pit in 130 AC
although the people of King's Landing
Riot when they hear of Helena's death
the mob kills dreamfire when they swarm
the captive dragons in protest of Queen
rhaenyra
also expected to appear in future
episodes of House of the Dragon is
tsarian who was written by Prince Darren
Targaryen the youngest son of viserys
and Allison a baby compared to the other
scaled steeds of House of the dragon
tasarian hatches around 120 AC dubbed
the blue Queen for her vibrant Cobalt
skills Darren's dragon is a smaller
Beast Prince Darren rides to sarin into
battle in the books to save Lord Ormond
Hightower the blue Queen Scouts ahead to
scare the opposition as Darren's forces
travel across Westeros she burns
bitterbridge after Damron receives
tragic news
vermouthor makes his on-screen debut in
the season 1 finale of House of the
Dragon the black queen
Damon seeks the dragon out to prepare
for the coming war against the greens
nicknamed the bronze Fury Verma Thor is
written by King jahiris the first
viserys's predecessor he's an impressive
Beast even among dragons second only to
vegar in size Reina Targaryen jairus's
sister and writer of dreamfire places
Verma Thor's egg in her infant brother's
cradle vermouth or hatches in 34 AC and
grows quickly by 48 AC he's already
larger than the other Targaryen dragons
say vegar Verma Thor also shows
affection for Silverwing the dragon
belonging to jairus's sister wife alisan
Fire and Blood suggests the two dragons
are a mated pair after jahiris's death
vermethor remains riderless until 129 AC
many would-be riders with traces of
Targaryen blood try to claim him but the
brawn series burns them all until he
bonds with Hugh Hammer a blacksmith's
bastard